welcome to this video playing Rafa an MA
from Argentina the sky is mostly high
rated 25 something d pretty high okay um
I think taking is what I've recommended
now 96 what about 36 is this or not e
six is probably not another problem
yeah I really forgot what I would i even
have had recommended myself in the
series of the calc on 95 is probably far
to risk him
yeah this is so I didn't I didn't think
about that news
okay so yeah night somewhere it's very
passive and did might take 25 okay it's
a it's a kind of show me attitude taking
only five so let go here Bishop f4 him
no it's taking okay he can he can take
take twice because of them this is
certainly fork hmm
yeah silly to spend time on that so
black what else I needed to do that yeah
this is an additional problem
Wow
yeah this is so it looks like black
sugar should lose out right somewhere
it's not sure where but hmm but it looks
like a terrible position hmm
night c7
hmm Jim
okay so let's see what he's doing now
and I think a 6 a-6 was a real threat
okay Queenie for this is obviously very
a very direct play
hmm what the heck
f6 what the move it was terrible
but is it so bad i mean just just wise
lot of time wise i spent a quite a while
here to get to this
yeah the bishop on the success sort of
hanging in midair
tweety five also Wow
yeah not sure maybe I'm losing with 20
years straight away it looks terrible
all night at five
yeah this is probably just not working
intending night a tu roop t6 night a
tool but okay 38 seconds just one one
problem of that check
hmm yeah
probably can can play any move about
Knight c3 here
check
check
time warning
yeah you give me give me some chances
here again I've counter play by playing
instantly for whatever reason maybe it's
it's still winning return now be three
threatened
don't understand what is there Queenie
to mate how do you prevent that check
checkmate what do what a strange game I
was completely lost of course yeah I
know every why why do you play instantly
here with the completely winning
position of course I'm yeah I can as
long as the king is that open I can try
to to to see have some trouble but we
have no idea what why you need to do all
this instantly white is still winning
but yeah I mean here just quite clear
that there are some threats but you can
play this without any any big big
trouble where am I going I probably
would have gone here
yeah why defense but it's it's a bit
more complicated than that was really
necessary yeah of course just the lucky
winner um the main issue here was the
opening where I was under and enormous
pressure yeah but I have probably 97's
just just ridiculous I didn't consider
night be five of course black can play
the normal Lucia Bishop before
efficiency five probably be being quite
okay um what this is this is really wow
okay i took here ok played that I was
asking myself what am i doing after that
but yeah probably nothing need to play
Bishop d6 here yeah it's terrible ok but
the way it did when did it also was was
probably just lost yeah maybe here I can
the computer already says I'm halfway in
the game with Bishop c5 but then yeah
it's a it's a disaster really yeah and
then I was losing material here only a
could only hope for a miracle which
somehow materialized thanks for watching